que devrait
savoir le président chinois xi de votre engagement envers taiwan nous
sommes d'accord avec ce que nous avons signé
il y a longtemps
et qu'il y a une politique chinoise selon laquelle
taiwan porte son propre jugement sur
son indépendance nous ne bougeons pas
nous ne les encourageons pas à être
indépendants nous  ce n'est pas leur
décision, mais les forces américaines défendraient-elles l'
île oui s'il y avait en fait une
attaque sans précédent, donc contrairement à l'ukraine
pour être clair, monsieur les
forces américaines les hommes et les femmes
défendraient taïwan en cas d'
invasion chinoise oui
vous